condragulations season nine of RuPaul's
Drag Race is upon us thank you you got
it right hello logos hit series is back
for its biggest season ever
may the best woman win our first show we
got Lady Gaga and she is turning it she
wrote to me several years ago on Twitter
saying please I want to be a judge on
your show and it's taken this long for
us to coordinate the schedules so that
she could be on how would you grade her
as a judge brilliant she is a class a
drag queen and she'd be the first one to
say that don't be a drag just be a queen
it was her idea to walk into the
workroom in costume as the world's
pre-eminent Lady Gaga impersonator well
it took our girls about 20 seconds to
realize oh no [ __ ] you are the real
Lady gaga
has there been another celebrity who has
reached out to you or said I love the
show that you were kind of surprised
that they tuned in I know that um
Scarlett Johansson has always been a fan
and she's always said I love the show I
want to be on the show the big issue is
with Gaga 2 is coordinating schedules
but I will say that every season we get
the greatest stars and the biggest fans
of our show mama likey
Wow go for it yes mama
[Music]
keeping things fresh keeping a spin
pulling some fierce epic stunts um that
is in our wheelhouse so honey you know
we can always keep it keep it real and
keep it exciting also exciting the show
is moving to a new network
we're on vh1 now which is in 93 million
homes and you know so funny price you
know we've known each other for a long
time we do this I've been out promoting
our show for so many years it's trying
to get people to come over to logo now
sort of my work is kind of made easier
by the fact we're on vh1 did a RuPaul
being an Emmy winner have anything to do
with that I'd like to think so
you know but uh you know ie who knows
you know I I don't do this really snatch
trophies price but the trophies are you
know let's gets cute it's cute which is
a cash myself
[Music]
[Music]